this is gudetama it's an egg yolk with a
little butt crack
good otama looks like a character
someone gave up on it has limbs but no
fingers or toes it has a mouth but no
teeth and yet people it can't get enough
of it
you can find it on backpacks cups
airplanes credit cards and it even has
its own themed cafe but Goethe Thomas
cute looks aren't the driving force
behind it's insane popularity its main
attraction is its lazy personality you
got she aqua dish 'l gudetama comes from
a japanese company called Sanrio
you might have heard of them they're the
creators behind Hello Kitty in 2013
Sanrio held a company-wide competition
to come up with a food based character
and once people voted gudetama didn't
end up on top today meet on the salmon
fillet came in first we actually started
to release product based on the salmon
fillet and its friends
gudetama the lazy eye came in second but
we also release products based on
gudetama and it really really took off
the appeal of Gouda thomas melancholy
stands in contrast to the american
concept of cuteness which is pretty
straightforward the idea of cute
represents goodness and optimism while
pessimism tends to define evil this is
evident in some of Disney's early films
as you can see there's a clear divide
between good and evil villains are
usually depicted as unappealing scary
and old draped in shadows and dark
colors they're meant to be identified as
evil which means that they can never be
cute
but in Japan there's more of a gray area
to this the word kawaii is widely used
to describe the quality of being like a
child which means that you can be cute
and lazy at the same time yeah kawaii is
a fascinating idea to me it's a very
vulnerable kind of cute it's for thing
like it's so cute that you make people
want to take care of you determined
merged in the 1970s and became a big
part of Japanese culture it was shown
through fashion hand
writing and even behavior and many
japanese artists and academics believe
that this popular culture on cuteness
happened for a reason
in japan the kawaii culture is often
linked to the country's post-world War
two years the idea is that because of
its trauma and defeat the country leaned
into its vulnerability and since then
the concept of kawaii has grown and even
form smaller subgroups
this is chemo kawaii which is sometimes
called ro kawaii and there's Yura kawaii
Yura means relaxed and calm according to
cartooning expert Iook Akita this
particular group became popular because
of the stress in modern society she
points out that in the u.s. people are
drawn to spas and meditation for
relaxation but in Japan you're as common
parents brings comfort to a lot of
people you can also see a shift in
scenarios characters throughout the
years they've started giving them a
personality to make them more relatable
when Hello Kitty came out in 1974 she
was more traditionally cute than
gudetama but she remained somewhat
emotionless she doesn't even have a
mouth to smile or frown with and that
makes her more of a blank canvas she can
be whatever we wanted to be but many
people feel a connection with gudetama
because of its cool any personality this
approach to cuteness extends beyond
appearances it evokes a reaction these
characters can make you laugh or feel
relaxed and you can relate to them by
observing their personality so at a time
of confusion and turmoil all around the
world maybe this is just what we need an
egg yolk with a little bun that's just
done dealing with life
[Music]
hola hijo del camión
[Music]